So here's what I did.
I wrote this little function to tell a story.
The story I want to tell is, over all the states, let's group the states in terms of
the number of pending points in that state,
and then for each of those number of pending points, say all the states for which
there are 10 points pending,
how many times did max_wins decide to roll versus how many times did
max_diffs decide to roll?
And just to consider the ones in which the 2 differ.
So throw away all of the states in which they take the same action.
Let's see what that looks like.
Let me just describe briefly what I do.
So I start off--I have a default dictionary and the default is that I have 2 values--
0 for max_wins and 0 for max_diffs.
Then I go through--get the 2 strategy functions to apply to the state.
If they're different, figure out what pending is and increment the pending count
for the person who decided to roll, and then I just go and print them out.
Here's the result.
It does tell a story. Look what's happening.
When I have a small number of points pending,
most of the time, the 2 strategies agree,
but when they differ, it's the max_diff strategy that's deciding to roll.
But as the number of points increase--the number of pending points increase,
we see it's max_wins who's willing to roll,
and max_diff not at all, so that's a perfect segregation between the 2
in this crossover point between 13 and 16.
We're here. Max_wins is rolling all the time with very high pending amounts.
But max_diff is never willing to do that.
So what must be happening here is 300 times max_wins has 24 pending points,
and he's willing to roll.
It must be because the opponent is just about to win and he says,
"Even though I'm risking 24, I still want to win the game, so I've got to roll."
Max_diff says, "Are you crazy?
I got 24 points on the board. I'm going to reap them right now.
And yes, I may lose, but I'm really going to cut down that differential."
So look what the story told us.
I thought that this man in the arena who was playing the max_diff strategy
was going to impress the NPA scouts by playing aggressively,
and it turned out that the story was completely different.
So what does that tell us.
Well, first it tells us that there is an interesting distinction about how we wrote our function
to maximize differential.
Note that the way we wrote it is we completely separated the what,
which is the rules of the game for how pig is played,
from the how of how does it make decisions,
and that was the perfectly general best actions.
So we didn't go in and say, we're going to write specific rules for pig to say,
if you're in such and such a position, do such and such.
Rather we just said, here's how pig works. Here's what I'm trying to do.
Maximize differential. You do the rest.
So the results that came back were surprising to me because I didn't really understand
how the what and the how interacted,
but I was still able to write a program that maximized the differential,
even though I didn't understand what that program is actually doing,
and that's the power of breaking up these aspects into what's happening
versus maximizing.
The second part that's interesting here is that I was able to do exploration.
So it wasn't just that I built a monolithic program that could do 1 thing.
It's that I build a set of tools that could explore the area.
When I wanted to understand something that was different from what I originally did,
I was able to do that because I had the tools around.